[Music]  foreign  lady here  we should be out there snacking on bad  guys  i am a predator  i need to be free you have got to get  control of your aggression  we will get hauled off into area 51.  live in my body you live by my walls  i'm sorry i don't know what came over me  please let me fix it so i can push it  again  you are a loser  brock  i want to give you my story  people love serial killers  cletus why me  that's mine  it's yours and what's  yours is mine  i have tasted blood before and that is  not it  all i ever wanted in this world  is carnage  i'm not increasing here  you feel like home to me  like family  oh wow you could just say i'm happy for  you that was going to be us hey i'm  happy for you  no  god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing  some serious couples counseling  [Music]  you